[Applause]
live to grantham and lincolnshire now
where conservative leadership candidate
rishi sunak is speaking let's listen
this leadership election will touch on
many issues
and i will travel the length and breadth
of our country to hear our members and
tell them
about my vision
and how we
need to change
but there is a core to this campaign
that stands us apart that represents the
best of us in the most testing of times
and that
is moral
courage
it may seem trite to say it
but but that's only because it is so
rare in our politics
the moral courage to tell the truth
even if it hurts me
the moral courage to raise issues even
if
they are uncomfortable
and
the moral courage to rise above the
smears and the hatred no matter how
baseless or unfair
we can be better and we will be better
this courage comes
from my family
my mum who ran the local chemist on
burgess road in southampton
and my dad
a local nhs gp
this country gave them the opportunity
for a better life
and they took it
they had three children me
my brother and my sister
and they gave everything so that we
could have more than they had
it is the most conservative of
conservative stories
and one that everyone here would
recognize
now my mum and dad are not here today
but my wife and children are and
whatever happens in this election
i've never been prouder to say to them i
love you all
[Applause]
now i've spent a few years in
westminster now and a couple of years at
the top of government and i can tell you
whilst it is full of decent and
hard-working people the system is broken
and no amount of undeliverable promises
are going to change that since the start
of this campaign
i've told you all some tough things to
hear
but i've told you them because
i'm a conservative
conservatives don't believe in burdening
future generations tomorrow because of
weakness today
that is not who we are and that is not
who i am
no
we believe in other things
conservatives believe in each other
because it is through each other not the
state or even the market that we achieve
the things that make life worth living
conservatives believe in honesty because
the foundation of all freedom is truth
and above all conservatives believe in
duty
and fidelity it is the core of our party
and our people
duty and fidelity to one another to our
families those we love to our neighbors
and friends
to our word and to our country
these are conservative values and
they are my values
and as your prime minister
i will turn these values into action for
you
because the problems we face
are so much more fundamental
than any candidate in this election has
told you
enough is enough
i am here to tell you that unless we
change unless we are competent enough to
grip this moment and make it work for
our country the challenges we face in
the coming months alone will push us to
the limit
this must not happen the stakes are too
high and the cost to our people too
great
if we are to deliver on the promise of
brexit
then we're going to need someone who
actually understands brexit the leaves
in brexit voted for brexit
[Music]
and if our challenges are great
then our answers must be too
we have national emergencies that must
be dealt with and
we have to tell the truth
we have to tell the truth about our nhs
and the pressure it is under
i've taken a lot of political pain to
make sure the nhs has what it needs and
i'm the candidate in this contest who
can say unequivocally the nhs will be
safe in my hands
we face the worst nhs winter crisis in
decades
tackling the backlogs is the biggest
public service emergency
we need a fundamentally different
approach
we will take the best of our covered
response and apply those lessons to
clearing the massive backlogs in the nhs
we have to tell the truth about
immigration
because our system
is still not working
it is simply unacceptable
to have the current situation where
criminal gangs are still trafficking
illegal immigrants to this country
exploiting loopholes in the legal system
and yes our compassion
we must
never lose that compassion
but we must be tougher
and we must be
uncompromising and as someone who is the
product of immigration
and the warm and welcoming embrace of
this country i know it can work but only
legally
we have to tell the truth
on criminal justice and sentencing
over half of all crimes are committed
by just nine percent of criminals
so if you want to deal with the crime
then any answer that doesn't target that
group of people who are committing most
of it
isn't worth the paper it is written on
we have to tell the truth about our
schools where the great education
reforms of michael gove have come under
threat
so we must now again
double down not just on teacher quality
and technology but genuine reform of our
curriculum
we have to tell the truth about national
security
yes
defense spending needs to increase
and i will never shortchange our armed
forces and my track record proves that
with the largest increases in defense
spending since the cold war
but simply saying three percent
isn't a plan
it's an arbitrary target
rather
we need to provide our military with the
resources it needs to do what it needs
to do to keep us safe
we have to tell the truth about the cost
of living and that there is no answer to
this problem other than to grip
inflation and bring it down
rising inflation
rising inflation is the enemy that makes
everyone poorer and puts at risk your
homes and your savings
and we have to tell the truth about tax
i will deliver more tax cuts i've
already made real progress as chancellor
but i will not put money back in your
pocket knowing that rising inflation
will only whip it straight back out
so we will tell the truth
no matter the cost
because
there can be no real change without
but real change is there i swear it
we can be better but it will only come
with radicalism we can grow our economy
creating more and better jobs with
higher wages and real progression if we
actually get businesses investing
so i'm going to reform our tax system
and make this the best country in the
world to invest
and it's not just about big businesses
this is about small businesses too this
is about our high streets
they can't grow if they can't invest and
i will fix that
we can revolutionize our education
system but only if we accept that the
status quo is not only unacceptable but
immoral
i don't care where you're born or who
your parents are your birthright should
be a world-class education
because today's education system is
tomorrow's economy
and
we can cut more taxes but only if we
defeat the enemy of inflation and that
can only happen
if we are honest about the ravages it
causes
we must see the danger in front of us
and act not pretend like it isn't
happening or more dreadful still
make the situation
worse putting people's homes and savings
at risk
i will deliver a lower tax economy i
will deliver tax cuts but tax cuts you
can believe in i will make that happen
we must be radical
we must change because if we don't we
can't rebuild our economy
we must be radical
we must change because if we don't then
brexit
will not be safe
and we must be radical we must change if
we are to beat kierstarma and the labour
party at the next election
because all the promises in the world
mean nothing if the country wakes up to
a labor government in 2024
all the evidence is clear i am the only
person who can beat labor i am the only
candidate who can protect the union and
i am the only candidate who can keep
brexit safe
today my campaign with party members
begins my campaign will represent the
very best of conservative values i will
give everything to earn every vote
but be in no doubt i am the underdog the
forces that be want this to be a
coronation for the other candidate
but i think members want a choice
and they are prepared to listen
and in the coming days
they will see
that i don't just offer change
i don't just offer grip
i'm offering
hope
we can
be better
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you right thank you very much now
i think we've got time some questions i
know there's some media over here
somewhere and then we'll take some
questions
from all of you as well right let's
start with the media charlie who we got
and we got a mic somewhere over there
tony wrote bbc can i ask you a question
perfect sorry yes you want to say your
name tony rowe from bbc hi tony um
is it a coincidence you've started your
campaign in margaret thatcher's hometown
[Applause]
there is that but i'm also delighted to
be here with my great friend your local
mp gareth but he's a brilliant champion
for this community
so look i think you know you the broader
point about your question is
yes i do believe that what i'm proposing
economically is what i would describe as
common sense bachelorism
the number one economic challenge our
country faces right now is inflation and
we must get a grip of inflation now and
not risk making the problem worse if we
don't do that we don't get a grip of it
it will cost families more in the long
run and i believe that that's what
margaret thatcher would have done deal
with the challenge of inflation first
get it out of the system and then get on
to delivering the tax cuts that we all
want to see
just one more one more question
it's jane from channel 4 news um you
talked about honesty telling the truth
about taxes
um
so are you saying that liz trust is
misleading party members or is she lying
when she says you can cut taxes without
pushing up inflation
well i've been very clear as you just
heard that this is the most pressing
challenge we face and i do believe that
it is the wrong approach
for the government at this moment to be
borrowing an extra tens and tens and
tens of billions of pounds at a time
when inflation is rising almost a double
digits at interest rates are already on
the rise
the risk of doing that is that you make
the situation worse everyone who has a
mortgage here and watching
having to pay hundreds if not thousands
of pounds more because of the impact
that it would have on interest rates and
beyond that i also don't believe it's
moral
i'm a conservative because i was brought
up to believe that you pay or you earn
what you need or for your spending that
was how i was raised in my household
with my family i did my mom's books in
her local chemist i sat around our
kitchen table doing the accounts every
month and that's what of course you need
to do when you run your small business
and that is a deeply conservative value
and if we are not the party of sound
money i don't see what the point in the
conservative party is
i think you'll all make up your own
views about that i've i've been very
clear that not only do i think it's the
wrong thing for the economy i do also
believe that it is immoral because there
is nothing noble or good about racking
up bills on the country's credit card
that we then pass on to our children and
our grandchildren
all right
charlie
i've got right i've got gentlemen here
yes
are you going to visit maggie's statue
oh well
well i hope so too i i've got time we're
going to have to nip over there
afterwards i will try and do it but no
it's a it's a great pleasure to be here
she was she's rightly someone who we all
look up to in our party for the change
that she brought to this country and as
i said economically she was prepared to
do some difficult things
and do them first for the long-term
benefit of our country that's what i'm
prepared to do and i believe that that's
what leadership is about
right yes sir
david collins from the sunny signs um hi
david you just said about um the powers
that
don't want you to kind of
succeed
i mean i was i was talking generically
but look obviously i start this part of
the contest
in the underdog position i was delighted
that thank you sir
[Laughter]
i was delighted in the parliamentary
stage of this i came top of the ballot
and if you think back a month or two ago
when people were speculating about this
contest if it would ever happen i was
written out of it and thanks to the hard
work and support of colleagues like
gareth i became top of the ballot just a
few weeks later drawing on all the
breadths and talents and wings of our
parliamentary party and i think what
that demonstrates is that i can bring
people together and in the same way that
i've done in our parliamentary party i'm
confident that i can do that in the
country as well so as i take out this
message that i've spoken to you today
about this message of change this
message of radicalism this message that
we need to grip these emergencies facing
our country and that i am the best
person to do that i'm confident that our
members will see that they will respond
to it and they will also recognize that
i'm the person who can beat kierstarma
when the next election comes
here
morning ma'am
no doubt appreciate lincolnshire is
mainly agricultural
and
regarding this trade agreement with
australia
will you give us assurance that it will
be debated in parliament when you become
prime minister yeah well you know thank
you ma'am that's an excellent question
and
we're here in lincolnshire today and
hopefully tonight if my campaign team
allow me i might get to sleep in my own
bed at home in north yorkshire and
yeah which which like you all here is a
very agricultural community um a bit
more hilly uh i think and
but my you know my neighbor is a farmer
my entire community are farmers and
farming is something that's incredibly
important to me when i first came to
parliament in spite of my business
background i rushed to get on the
agriculture and farming select committee
because i thought that supporting my
community my rural community was
absolutely vital in my role as a member
of parliament so i can reassure you
that i will run the most pro-countryside
pro-farming government that you have
ever seen and you know what if i don't
my own constituents won't re-elect me
let alone anyone else
right tommy
yes ma'am
hello i'm juliette donahue former
councillor of rushcliffe council but
also a nurse that worked during the
pandemic and
just for the press particularly channel
4 that he's not told me to say this by
the way
thank
we you the lead in europe uh we never
know that deeply that was a lot of media
we never lacked anything and the
procurement you did in a global crisis
was astounding and just thank you so
much
for all your hard work and also
[Music]
prime minister boris johnson because
what people don't see is in public
service
the work you put in and you don't do it
for the money because you're not that
well paid
you do it because you care about your
communities
and i just wanted to thank you and all
this negativity about the pandemic
i have no criticism and i felt we were
in a safe pair of hands
in the uk under the government so thank
you particularly
julia that's very very kind of you to
say thank you for that and you know can
i can i just pay an enormous tribute to
you and all of your colleagues for what
you did and we saw the best of this
country over the last two years i i do
you'll think back to that first press
conference that i gave when i was
introduced to you as your new chancellor
and i talked at the beginning of it all
about the small acts of kindness
that would be done by us and to us by
millions of people and that's what we
saw over the past couple of years but it
started with the heroic efforts of you
and your colleagues in the health
service health care is so important to
me as i said my mum was a local chemist
my dad was an nhs gp i grew up working
in her shop delivering medicines to her
patients and like you i saw the
unbelievable impact on a community that
good healthcare can provide and good
people can provide that's my inspiration
for wanting to be a member of parliament
and it's my parents story that has
inspired me to be here wanting to be
your prime minister next but let me just
ask everyone to join me in saying thank
you to you and all your colleagues
and then we'll
yeah well that's an absolutely excellent
question now china poses a threat to our
security it poses a threat particularly
to our economic security but thereby our
national security it's an authoritarian
regime with values that are different to
ours and as prime minister i would be
robust in standing up for the values
that we believe in and protecting us
against the threat that china poses to
our security
specifically there was a speech that the
heads of the fbi and mi5 gave very
recently jointly about the threat that
china posed and i thought that was an
excellent speech and that is the
approach that i would follow as prime
minister but it requires us to think
differently because the threats that we
face have changed you know but if you
find companies that we don't know where
they're from trying to infiltrate our
universities our civic society buying up
the best technology that we're creating
out of our universities those are new
21st century threats and we must guard
against them and i will tell you as your
prime minister have every confidence
that's exactly what i will do
okay
we got time for another one yes
sir
phil stevens
not necessarily that they have a good
campaign
on that note
who's trying to distance themselves more
from the forest you or mrs
all right phil will win yeah no well
actually you know that's a very good
point when you're talking about those
mps you definitely were not talking
about your local mp garrett who is
absolutely exceptional and no so i i've
been very clear and open about my views
about the prime minister i've said he's
one of the most remarkable people that
i've ever met and it was a great
privilege to serve in his government for
almost two and a half years and to enjoy
some extraordinary successes that we
shouldn't forget there was no other
person i believe who three years ago
could have broken that brexit deadlock
got that done you remember the paralysis
our country was facing at the time he
alone was able to break that he alone
was able to deliver that election
victory and it's because of him that we
managed to successfully roll out the
vaccine support the country through the
pandemic as we heard from juliet but
then also to stand up to ukraine first
and before others and he deserves
enormous credit from those things and
i'm not i'm not going to rewrite history
and pretend that those aren't wonderful
things but for me personally it got to a
point where enough was enough and i felt
i had to leave from government that
wasn't an easy decision it wasn't
a happy decision but now at this point
we have to look forward the choice now
for all our members is who is the best
person to lead this country through the
challenges we face you heard a little
bit from me today about those
emergencies that we face whether it's
tackling illegal migration whether it's
tackling the backlogs in the nhs whether
it's getting a grip of inflation and
rebuilding the economy so that we can
cut taxes whether it's keeping brexit
safe and realizing all the opportunities
i'm the person who can best do that and
crucially i am the best person that when
the time comes can beat kierstarma and
deliver a historic fifth election
victory for the conservative party
thank you
thanks very much